جمهوريه السودان محاطه بعده دول من ثلاثه
اتجاهات تحدها سبعه دول شمالا وغربا
وجنوبا مع تعدد المعابر البريه والممرات
المائيه لها الجاره الشماليه مصر تتشارك
مع السودان بحدود طولها
1176 كيلومترا في منطقه صحراويه بشكل عام
وبها معبران رئيسيه هما اشكيت وارجين
ليبيا على الجهه الاخرى تربطها بالسودان
حدود تمتد لثلاثمائه 182 كيلومترا في بيئه
تتنوع تضاريسها ما بين صحراء وجبال وسهول
يوجد معبر واحد بين الدولتين هو العوينات
قرب المثلث الحدودي بين الدولتين ومصر
الى الغرب من السودان شريط حدودي مع تشاد
طوله
1403 كيلومترات ومعبر رئيسي يربط بين
مدينتي الجنينه في دارفور وادري في تشاد
اكثر حدود للسودان تربطها بجمهوريه
افريقيا الوسطى وتقل عن 200 كيلومتر مع
معبر وحيد هو ام دافوج بالقرب من هذه
الحدود نجد اطول حدود للسودان وهي مع دوله
جنوب السودان طولها 1900 كيلو متر وبها
عشره معابر حدوديه متفق عليها بين
الدولتين الا انه لم يتم افتتاح كل هذه
المعابر في جنوب شرق البلاد تشترك السودان
مع اثيوبيا بسبعمائه واربعه واربعين كيلو
مترا من الحدود مع معبر رئيسي هو الفشقه
سابع الدول المحاذيه للسودان اريتريا مع
حدود طولها 605 كيلومترات ومعبر وحيد هو
طوكر
سيدنا الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات